こんチャンネル必要です皆さん緑色い食べ物飲み物を見たことありますでしょうか
結構世の中にあるんですよ at 買ってきてもこれぐらい結構見つかって食べ物って
言ったらもキュウリもそうですし
ネギもそうです今んすいとヴァシュ
そのわかんないす合成って基本的に緑色妹のお色を抜くんでやろうと思えばここのやつ
全部
答弁できるんですよやってみましょうかあっあのこれもちょっとだけじゃじゃあ
いろいろ
ほか緑も全部できちゃうから極力みのみをなくしたいところであります
これはほぼないようですでは土産に行きます
day
はいが抜けましたね完全に安の答弁になっております外の柄とガール後林ですけども
基本的に合成製では緑色妹当面できるんですよそこで私は思いますてぃんぐ
食べ物透明に食べてでもうわかる雪あるんですよ不正かじゃないですか9リターンで
食べたら絶対ポリポリ言いますし大ばってんですからねこういう葉っぱ食べたらきっと
何か苦くて種類かになると思うし
米は食べてお腹ですって言うしそれぞれなんでなく特徴があるんで僕はわかると思うん
です予定で今回の動画はためを透明にして食べてもなんとなくで何かはグラセフ
検証していきたいと思います私今が出題者に徹するので後から回答者に来ていただき
ましょう
では行こう
ようこそ開花さがをしたり本日私
クイズー
人ぞ
ピカデリー
池田家担当しますよろしくお願いしまーすまあ
私問題を準備しましたお二人に緑色色の
ごめんできるじゃないですかはいオッケーね緑色い食べ物飲み物いろいろなものを食べ
たり飲んだりしたんですけどもそれを任される問題が不透明になっているもの食べてる
んだで知ってるで
屋敷を出し合ってそれを磨いていただきたいなるほどなるほど分かりましたぜたりかと
いうと答えられなそうナンバーカー食べ物
トップあるんで違って調理して知識が必要な皆さんが言う
この2人で今日は世代していきたいとおもいます
なんと全問正解者際には
ジャック枚プレゼントで事がええええええ
ええやつです今日はねー月です55中ですね80 f 2216じゃないから版単相ね
当てればいいですよね当てればいいだけで結構問題す多いんですけども緑ない食べ物皆
さんそうっ
第2巻何かを知っ行けば必ずくれると思います頑張って下さいねまず
一応ねっ
ん
[音楽]
はいこれは最初なんでねぇ
does 可能これは8分ん
さあもう僕完璧完璧完璧二派の皆さん入った分かります9位
ファイナル r 家
米がで大
ああああああん
[音楽]
なもうねしなくだけだったら楽勝ですじゃあに米です
はいっ
お願い金ああああと当然
もう一回それでしまったん
車移動でから答え出てますよ
未だにも女だから打者明石のサヤエンドウ
入りませんファイナルアンプ
西街道方
100万貰ったと思うさあ
パッケージを緑色だったから学んでいけるかなてバレちゃう合わせてさんも見えません
こちらです
[音楽]
a
ねええええ
[拍手]
オエー
スウープはっはー
これはちょっとパッドにお菓子じゃなさそうな雰囲気がありました
もう1回外本当にもう一回お願いしてきたとかを誇示がいいと思いますねこれ
[音楽]
a
ああねええええどっ
これつを指してに違ってなってるんででもそんな立ってないですね
見た感じだったんですねこれなにこれ
復刻ですおごめんなさい寄せいただきますはいお願いします
チンゲンサイはロランスファイルあーする
性が大
ねーっいいねちょっと柔道家があるなんてまでアーマーじゃないかぁぁぁぁ
次行きましょうごはん難しくありますよはい
ちょっと中から問題で
近く調査
ああ
スプーンっ
うーんジュルッたんだもゼリーくっくりのプリオン
黄緑じゃん抹茶プリンと
あっては最後に用事が見てなんですよねうんかしたいなしてもう1回坊からのもう1回
お願い所
ああ
してからないですよちゃん
陽気みたのでもなくスーパーカップの抹茶のなんかポン
カップ見て何吸っ
ああ
ぞ合図だじゃ行ってないっす ips アイス s ってことはありましたでしょうか
ok さいっては描いをお願いいたします
世界は抹茶位数ファイナル nisa
商品名まで行っています正解です
あっ
ボール俺は絶対5分くらいでカップがわかったんですかねちょっと茶色いこれがノック
あんですよ
あっはっだけどもだねはいそれ
amaran バッハ
あった
ああああああ
ですねうん何で切れ下手くそんだ言ったまで欲しかったです綺麗ですか
じゃああースイカ世界ですかっ派
ふとできますねはい r です
ああああ分かりましたなんかと思いますございました今回は弟その反応でちょっと簡単
だったら来なかったんですよね
ピーマン1 f yeah
[拍手]
音でしたねこれ感じの姉じゃあもう半分がエストレア車
3 editor アメリカっ
ふーん
不安くるっていうか
[音楽]
ん
はぁ
ああ
答えの方お願いしますガブドビーメロンソーダは犬
ファイナルあーず確か正解です
だからあなたが知ってらっしゃい
[音楽]
これまで病気のから直送ですよ明日こそあーさー次ものですこちら
終わりましょうコンビです54まず自社あるんですください
どこ速だからもうちょっと大きい声出すございましたでしょうか
ございましたでは正解の方お願いします
ローソンに売ってる刻まれたね日だぜローソン限定したのかわかりませんが正解で
ああああっ
[音楽]
赤 lost なばローソンしかないいきましょうもうけっこ終盤です
3難しい
ん
あんま
入ってくるんですが保存べきですはい
夏季号白くのメロアージュ
ファイナル interesting renta
正解方
ああああああん
ぽーっ
どこから急に出る出ないですからねハイツところしていきましょう
大好きなのでこちらです
愛永
3突
see 等を見せないしたことをのごすって
終わってしまいましたもう1回店もう1回行きません
[音楽]
吸い取っ
俺めっちゃを感じです何も出てこないえええ
最初の孤児
最初の持ち場すです
数対1ではいおさらいです
e 棟
風味に調味料かっ
ペッパ
ピン等まあしたとおっしゃっているおっしゃるですバッジを使う済ませる込
いいカバジェロぱせりんにん火星が立って下さなければジャンボリーも店があります
ブーケですございましたかはいお願いしまーす
ツイートば寿退団はいっ
算是画像4ブルー
ひどかったよもっと無難ですひまっはい
[音楽]
心はとかもうすぐココでもあるねこれは大間違いですよ
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
ん
[音楽]
うわぁさあ最初のない
られ
色は落ち着いたこれを ok しています
[音楽]
うーんあんまり取り6なくて方面章トータル自分は傷あるて事件がはずです
どっちも進める私もを持ち系なかなぁ
の額で目下もさんお願いします
[音楽]
うーん難しいでさせが最終問題をなかっ
マスカットの組あるじゃないですか北韓心コロッケを得ないんじゃないです
本意なってなるんですよそれかもしれない遠いですよね
矢部頃中央最終的にコイン不満なまとまりましたでしょうか車
ございましたではお願いします
[音楽]
組の頃のますカッター c
ファイナルアンサーん j
jr
シャワーなんせバッハ
くださいいい
[音楽]
ブーブー l パッケージ